JULIE: OK, everybody,
how we doing?
Having fun?
All right.
I'm Julie Wiskirchen, and I
work on the Talks at Google team
here at Google LA.
And today we're
excited to welcome
one of our very own
Googlers, Rachel Searles, who
is also an author.
Rachel grew up in
Michigan's Upper Peninsula
where she spent her childhood
reading everything available,
studying languages, and
dreaming of seeing the world.
She lives with her
husband in Los Angeles
where she's hard at work on the
next book in "The Lost Planet"
series.
And today she's going to
talk about her first novel,
a sci-fi adventure story
called "The Lost Planet."
So let's all give
Rachel a big hand.
RACHEL SEARLES: Hello.
So, yeah.
What she said.
I'm a Googler, but
I also write books.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about myself
and how I became an author,
starting with where I'm from.
Planet Earth.
The United States.
What state is that?
Michigan, yes.
And I'm from the upper peninsula
there, that bit at the top,
right next to Canada.
This is what it looks
like in the summer,
and this is what it
looks like in the winter.
It's very cold there.
It snows a lot.
When I was a kid this is how
I went to school every day.
By dog sled.
Just kidding, my dog
couldn't really pull me.
But it snowed all the time.
It was cold.
I stayed inside a lot,
and so in my spare time,
I really liked to read.
There are a lot of pictures of
me from my childhood reading.
Who here likes to read?
Yes, good.
Everybody.
I read.
I had really cool glasses,
because this was the '80s.
And when I couldn't read, I read
some more with my companion.
Does he look pretty happy
to be there with me?
AUDIENCE: No.
RACHEL SEARLES: No.
Oh, am I in your way?
Some of my favorite
books when I was a kid.
"A Little Princess."
Lloyd Alexander's books.
This is "The Castle of Lear."
And maybe you know this guy.
Roald Dahl.
Yeah.
He's pretty funny.
Those are great books.
Because I liked to read
so much, I thought a lot
about maybe writing
my own books.
So when I was about
six years old,
I started writing some stories.
This is my first story.
It's called "Birthdays."
It was about five pages long.
Yeah.
I was six years old,
so just beginning.
And I knew some day I
would like to be an author.
I knew right away that I
wanted to make stories as fun
to read as the ones
I loved to read.
But I thought about a
lot of other options.
I thought about what I
wanted to be when I grew up.
How many of you know what you
want to be when you grow up?
Oh wow, a lot of you.
What you want to be?
AUDIENCE: I want to
be a police officer.
RACHEL SEARLES:
A police officer.
How about you?
AUDIENCE: I want to be a doctor.
RACHEL SEARLES: A doctor.
You?
AUDIENCE: I want to
be a pediatrician.
RACHEL SEARLES: A pediatrician.
Outstanding.
Huh?
Who was that?
An inventor.
Last one.
What do you want?
AUDIENCE: I want to be
a computer animator.
RACHEL SEARLES:
Computer animator.
Well, you're in the
right place for that.
So I thought about
different options.
My first thing that I wanted
to be was an entomologist.
That's somebody who
studies insects.
I thought that would
be a lot of fun
because I really liked ants.
I thought they were cool.
I really liked praying mantises.
We don't have any praying
mantises in Michigan,
where I grew up.
So I just read about
them, but I thought
they sounded interesting.
But there was a problem with my
plan to become an entomologist,
and that problem was spiders.
That was a deal breaker.
I couldn't do
something where I had
to handle spiders every day.
So I thought about what
else I'd like to do.
I thought, maybe I'd
like to be a nurse.
Seemed like a
really good career.
There are a lot of jobs
for nurses out there.
Everybody's always
looking for a nurse.
It'd make my grandma
really happy.
My grandma wanted a
nurse in the family.
Not quite a doctor, but close.
But what does a nurse do?
Cleans up after sick people
every day, and that is messy.
So I thought, well,
maybe that's not for me.
Maybe that's not my personality.
So eventually, I
came on the idea
that I wanted to be an
international diplomat.
And I wanted to travel the
world and learn new languages
and meet interesting people.
And that was about the time
I was graduating high school.
So I made a plan.
I got a bachelor's degree in
political science in German.
I moved to Germany
for three years.
I learned to speak
German fluently.
I thought maybe I'd
like to be a lawyer,
so I worked at a law firm.
Killed that idea
pretty quickly, I
decided that was not
what I wanted to do.
I lived in Istanbul for
half a year in Turkey.
And I came back and I
went to grad school,
and I studied
journalism eventually.
The international diplomat
lost its glamour after a while,
but I thought, well,
I like to write.
And so journalism school
seemed like a good fit.
But when I graduated journalism
school, I changed my mind.
Again.
I didn't really like
having to talk to strangers
and bother them for information
they didn't want to give me,
so instead I got a really
great job working at Google.
And what I do at Google is
I work on the search quality
team.
And we look for bad
websites and weed them out
of the search results.
And it was a great
job, it is a great job
with a great team, a great boss.
I mean, do you think working at
Google is a good place to work?
Yeah?
But.
There was one big, hairy but.
I hadn't forgotten
about my childhood
dream of becoming an author.
So after I'd been working at
Google for maybe six or seven
years, I started to write
again in my free time.
Usually on business
trips in my hotel room,
write a little story.
I never wrote too much.
I'd get distracted.
There's a lot of things to do
when you have a full time job.
I got married.
I had friends.
There's always movies to
watch, good TV shows to watch.
It's hard to really concentrate
on something like writing.
But eventually in 2006,
I came up with this idea.
I wanted to write a
story about a boy who
goes on an adventure in space.
So I started writing in 2006.
This is the first page.
I was calling it "The
Babel Project" at the time.
And it was about a boy.
He was on a planet.
He got into a fight
with his parents.
He hung out with his neighbor.
He went to get sister.
It was a very boring story.
And I wrote about 30
pages of it in 2006
and realized that
I didn't really--
it wasn't a good story.
So 2008, I came up with the
idea to make it more adventurous
by starting this story with
the boy not having any memory
when he wakes up.
Start it as a mystery.
And so I started writing that
around the beginning of 2008.
By the end of 2009, so two years
later, I had about 100 pages.
And 100 pages over
two years, that
averages out to
about 40 words a day.
That's pretty slow.
If I was going to keep
writing at that pace,
it would've taken me
six years to finish
the first draft of this book.
And I thought, well,
that's not going to work.
So I made a plan.
You can see my
Google Calendar here.
I decided, it was my
New Years resolution,
I was going to write
a thousand words a day
until I finish the book.
I had never actually
finished writing a book.
So you can see all these little
yellow spots on my calendar.
That's where I logged my word
count every day that I wrote.
I didn't write every single day.
You can see the kind of reddish
pink-- those are my goals.
So every 10 days, I'd put down
40,000 words, 50,000 words.
Those are my word count goals.
And I didn't always
hit them, but I tried.
I kept up, and I actually
finished the book
in four months.
So, what was this?
April of 2010.
I had a finished book.
It was huge.
It was an enormous book.
It had potential, but
it was a first draft.
And the first draft of any
book is not a good book.
It's the potential
for a good book.
So I thought, how do
I make this better?
How do I make this something
that I could actually
get published?
So I went out and I met
some writer friends.
I joined critique groups.
And I spent a year and a
half rewriting this book
with critique groups.
And a year and a
half later, I was
ready to send my book
out in the world.
I thought it was a lot better.
Hi.
So I wrote a query letter.
And this is an idea of what
a query letter looks like.
It's just an email to
an agent, because you
don't want to send your book
directly to a publisher.
You want to send it to
an agent, an agent who
will help you find publishers.
So I had this letter saying,
dear agent, this is my book.
A few paragraphs, this
is what it's about.
And I sent out about 60 of
these to different agents.
About 10 at a time,
not all at once.
And over half a year,
I got 50 of these.
Dear Rachel, thank you
kindly for thinking of me
for "The Fulcrum."
That was the title at the time.
It seems promising,
but I'm afraid it's not
an ideal fit for my
list at this time.
I wish you much luck all the
same with your agent search.
Happy Holidays.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Because
they're telling me
they don't want to
represent my book.
50 times in a row,
people told me
they didn't want to
represent my book.
And there were times where
I thought, man, maybe I
should write a different book.
Maybe this book's no good.
Maybe I should write a
different kind of book.
Maybe I should just
stop writing together.
But every time, something
would push me along,
and I'd send out
another 10 queries.
And eventually, after half
a year, I got one of these
from an agent who said,
thank you for your patience
while we've pulled together our
notes on "The Burned Planet."
I was calling it "The Burned
Planet" at this point.
While we're writing
them up more firmly,
I'd love to set a time
to discuss with you
this week as well.
So, I had a phone
call with an agent.
And when I talked to her
she said she loved the book.
She wanted to represent me.
We did some light
revisions together.
She took the book out.
Two weeks later, I think we
sent it to a dozen publishers.
Two weeks later, we had several
offers from major publishers.
We got to take it to
auction, had publishers
bidding on the book.
It was very exciting.
And we sold it.
We ended up getting a two
book deal with Macmillan.
So this was 2012.
It takes a while after you sell
books for it to be published,
because this book didn't
come out until this January.
So it was very exciting.
And it goes to show-- I
mean, to me that says,
just because a lot
of people say no--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES:
(WHISPERING) OK, thank you.
(SPEAKING NORMALLY) Say
no, I don't want this,
it doesn't mean it's bad.
It just means you
have to keep trying.
So people ask me,
why science fiction?
Why did I choose to
write science fiction?
There are all kinds of
books you can write.
Do you guys like
science fiction?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RACHEL SEARLES: Do you like
"Star Wars?" "Star Trek?"
Did you see "Avatar?"
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
RACHEL SEARLES:
"Doctor Who," yes.
My kind of person.
So there are two main
kinds of fiction.
There's realistic fiction, and
this takes place in our world.
And maybe it's set
in a different time.
Maybe it's historical.
Maybe it's a funny book,
maybe it's a serious book.
But it conforms to the
rules of our world.
It takes place in the same
kind of place we live in.
Then there's on the other side,
there's speculative fiction.
AUDIENCE: Harry Potter.
RACHEL SEARLES: Yes.
Speculative fiction takes
place in a made up world.
There's fantasy.
There's dystopian.
There's horror.
But my favorite is
science fiction.
Who can tell me what
book this is from?
Anybody?
"A Wrinkle In Time."
Who did that?
Very good.
So, this is "A Wrinkle in Time."
Very good book if you
haven't read it yet.
Why do I like science fiction?
I like space science
fiction in particular.
Because I think space
is really exciting.
It's vast.
This is a picture
of our solar system.
And the planets are to scale.
That's the size of the sun.
That little dot over
from it, that's Earth.
That's how big the sun
is compared our planet.
But the scale is wrong, because
the distances at this size,
I would have to spread this
all around the building
to get the distances right.
Because the distances
between planets are so huge.
So, the distance between
Earth and the sun
is about 93 million miles.
And right now the fastest
that we can travel in space
is 36,000 miles.
That's the New Horizons
that's going out
towards Pluto right now.
So traveling at that speed,
it would take us 107 days
to reach the sun at
our very fastest speed.
But we don't measure
by-- ooh, what did I do?
There it goes.
But we don't measure it
by how fast we can travel.
How fast we travel in space,
we measure this by light year.
What's a light year?
AUDIENCE: How far light
can travel in a year.
RACHEL SEARLES: How far
light can travel in a year.
Very good.
So, light travels at the speed
of 186,000 miles a second.
It gets to us from the sun
in about eight minutes.
But one light year is equal
to about six trillion miles.
That's really far.
And the next closest
star to our solar system
is Proxima Centauri, and
it is 4.3 light years away.
And in miles, that's
about 25 trillion miles.
So if we were traveling to that
star at our speed of 36,000
miles, it would take us
82,000 years to get there.
So right now, we're not
traveling to any other planets.
But it's exciting, because
maybe someday we will.
With fantasy, fantasy's all
about unicorns and wizards
and vampires and things
that we know aren't real.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Yes.
But the difference
with science fiction
is that science fiction has
the potential to be real.
Maybe someday we will be able
to travel at the speed of light.
Maybe someday we will
travel to other stars.
And I think that's
very exciting.
Other things I like about
space science fiction.
When you look-- so it's 4.3
light years to the next star.
But that works in reverse.
So we don't see light
from that star--
that light doesn't
reach us for 4.3 years.
And that's the closest star.
There are stars that
are tens of thousands--
there are stars that are
millions of miles away.
So it takes-- millions of
light years away, not miles.
Sorry.
So it takes those stars-- their
light takes tens of thousands,
or millions of
years to reach us.
So when we look up
at the sky, what
we see is the light from
millions of years ago.
So it's more like we're
looking back in time.
AUDIENCE: Like Doctor Who.
RACHEL SEARLES: Like
Doctor Who, exactly.
I like space because
space looks cool.
Look at that.
That's a storm on Jupiter.
That's a moon of Saturn.
That's a sun flare.
I like space because
space is full.
It might have aliens.
Good aliens.
Bad aliens.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES:
But these planets
are-- other solar systems are
millions light years away.
So we can't say whether or
not they might not exist.
Maybe they don't look like this.
Maybe they don't
look anything like us
or anything we've imagined,
but they might be out there.
I like space because space
stores are full of adventure.
They're always very exciting.
Light saber fights, spaceship
chases, battles with aliens.
Very exciting.
But my favorite
thing about space
can be best described
by this book here.
It's called "From the
Earth to the Moon."
Have you heard of this book?
It was a book written in 1865,
around the time of the Civil
War.
It was written a long time ago.
But it's about a
club in Baltimore
that wants to send three
people to the moon.
At the time they had no
idea how to get to the moon.
They had no idea
what was up there.
They didn't know if we could
land there and walk around
in our regular,
everyday clothes.
But in 1969, over
100 years later,
we did land someone on the moon.
So today's space fiction might
be tomorrow's space reality.
Maybe someday we will travel
to these other solar systems,
and see other planets,
and meet some aliens.
Who knows?
To me, space fiction,
science fiction
is about imagining the future.
I stole this picture off the
internet because I love it.
This is "Star Trek," predicting
the future since 1966.
You can see on the left in "Star
Trek," how we imagined-- back
in 1966, 1987,
1988-- we imagined
these futuristic devices
that people might use someday
to communicate, and now
those exact same devices
exist in our everyday lives.
Cell phones, iPads, video
conferences, Google Glass.
So these are the reasons why
I like reading and writing
science fiction.
Now, I'm going to read
to you guys a little bit
from the beginning of my book.
Has anybody read this yet?
Yes?
Surprised me.
OK.
Chapter one.
The boy opened his eyes to a
sky the color of melted butter
and a sense of
inexplicable terror.
He sucked in a ragged
gasp of air and sat up.
The pain followed
a second later,
smacking the back of
his head like a club.
The world swam
around him in a blur.
He grasped for simple facts.
Where he was, how
he'd gotten here.
Why he hurt.
Why he could barely see.
Nothing.
Shoving aside his confusion,
he pushed himself to one knee
with a grunt.
The muggy air seemed
to vibrate, but he
couldn't tell
whether it was real
or whether he was imagining it.
He squinted hard
enough to make out
the gray shape of
a nearby building,
and something vast
and green behind it.
What was this place?
A hand landed on his shoulder.
With a cry of
surprise, he turned
and saw a blurry figure
crouched beside him.
It took a moment to unscramble
what the person was shouting.
"Who are you?
How to get past the fence?"
Fence?
He shook his head.
Something had began
to rise in his chest.
A bubble of vital information.
What was it?
His mouth worked
silently, trying
to pin down the words dancing
at the edge of his tongue.
The pain swelled, crowding
everything else out,
and he felt himself
slipping away.
"Guide the star,"
he shouted just
before the blackness closed in.
"Hey, hey wake up."
He opened his eyes.
The blinding sunlight was gone.
He was somewhere dim and quiet,
breathing processed indoor air.
A dark haired boy leaned
over him, studying his face.
"There you are."
For a moment he struggled
to form a slurred question.
"Where am I?" "I
brought you inside.
You're safe.
You're in my house."
He stared at the
pale, sharp faced boy.
Was the same person who
had spoken to him outside?
"Uh, who are you?"
"OK, you're welcome.
I'm Parker.
Now who on Taras are you?
Where did you come from?"
Letting the questions
fly over his head,
he looked past Parker to
take in his surroundings.
He was lying in a bed inside
a small, empty bedroom.
The only light came
through an open door.
He turned this head to see
what lay beyond the door
and winced as throbbing
erupted behind his eyes.
Parker had crossed
his arms as if he
were waiting for something.
Did he know this Parker?
He didn't think so.
His eyelids grew heavy
and began to droop.
"No, you don't.
Stay awake."
Parker reached down and
slapped his cheek lightly,
but he may as well
have swung a hammer.
Jagged bolts of pain raced
across the boy's skull
and he cried out.
Parker raised his
hands. "Whoa, sorry.
Good lords, what happened
to you?" "What happened?"
he repeated, looking
for the answer himself.
The confusion he felt outside
started to rise again.
"Um, yeah.
How did you get through
the fence?" "Fence?"
Parker shook his head.
"What is wrong with you, kid?"
"Kid?"
He felt like a bleeding
idiot repeating everything,
but it was if his
brain had shorted out.
Why didn't he know the
answer to these questions?
Why didn't he know anything?
"Yeah, what are you, 13?"
Parker said, with
the authoritative air
of someone much older.
He couldn't have been
more than 14 himself.
How old am I?
"I don't know," he admitted.
"Don't know how old you are?
You some kind of run away?"
"I-- I don't know." "What do you
mean, you don't know?
Who are you?"
Who am I?
He stared into
Parker's gray eyes
and his confusion began
to twist into fear.
"I don't know," he
repeated a third time,
his voice dropping to a whisper.
Parker's face lit
up with a grin.
"Are you kidding me?
You must have really gotten
your brain scrambled.
I know what to do.
Hold on a sec."
He left the room and
returned a minute later,
thrusting a mirror
into the boy's face.
Wincing, the boy hoisted
himself up on one elbow
and grabbed the mirror with
the other hand steady it.
His stomach plummeted and
his heart began to race.
A sandy haired,
ashen faced stranger
stared back at him from
the mirror with wild eyes.
A low gasp diverted his
attention for the mirror.
"Oh, lord," said Parker,
staring past the boy
at something behind him.
Tingling panic raced over
his skin. "What is it?"
Parker was already
backing toward the door.
"I'm going to call the
doctor," he said quickly.
He turned and ran, his
pounding footsteps echoing down
the hall.
Frantic, the boy in the bed
wrenched his head around.
Fresh explosions of pain knocked
him back into unconsciousness,
but not before he glimpsed
the bright red stain
spreading on his pillowcase.
So I will stop there, and
now open it up to questions.
Do you guys have any
questions for me.
You?
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to autograph the books?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I going
Yes, I will.
You?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: What other
books have I written?
This was the first book
I ever actually finished,
and I was describing
how long it took me.
It took me, overall, maybe four
years to write the whole thing.
I've written the
second book since,
because there's a
sequel, but I wrote
that one in about four
months last summer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the next
book going to be named?
AUDIENCE: What's my next
I know the name,
but my publish--
it's not called The
Lost Planet Two.
I can't announce the name yet,
because my publisher hasn't
announced it, but it's
about a moon this time.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
RACHEL SEARLES: Ah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why are you
afraid of spiders?
RACHEL SEARLES: Why am
I afraid of spiders?
AUDIENCE: Because they can
bite and some are poisonous.
RACHEL SEARLES: They
can bite, they can jump.
I don't know.
I think they're just the
creepiest thing on the planet.
You?
AUDIENCE: They're
actually-- I would
like to correct the
person-- [INAUDIBLE]
They're all--
they're all venomous.
Because they need their venom
and webs to trap and immobilize
their prey.
RACHEL SEARLES: Yes.
That's how they stay alive.
They're just creepy
as all get out.
AUDIENCE: How long did it
get to make the first idea?
RACHEL SEARLES: How
long did it take
me to get the first
ideas to write my book?
Years.
Well, first I had the idea of
just writing a space adventure.
But the time between
coming up with the idea
that I wanted to write
a space adventure
and knowing that I
wanted to write a space
adventure about a boy who
lost his memory who's getting
chased across the galaxy
was probably two years.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are there wars?
RACHEL SEARLES:
Are there any wars
in any of the
books that I wrote?
There is a war that happened in
the past that they talk about,
but there's not a war
going on in the book.
AUDIENCE: Why did you write
a boy, a girl, [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: He's
asking me to describe
the people on the cover.
There's a lot of
characters in the book,
and all the important
ones are on the cover.
You have to read the book
to find out who they are.
AUDIENCE: But other
books, like-- [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES:
Oh, no thank you.
Thank you.
Anyway, yes.
You?
AUDIENCE: In the
book, does it explain
what happened in the past?
RACHEL SEARLES:
In the book, does
it explain what
happened in the past?
Do I explain what
happened to him
by-- by the end of the
book, he figures out
what happened to him before
the start of the book, yes.
AUDIENCE: What happened to him?
What happened to the boy?
RACHEL SEARLES: You
have to read the book.
AUDIENCE: What?
RACHEL SEARLES: What?
Yes, you?
AUDIENCE: What
kind of book is it?
Adventure?
Comedy?
RACHEL SEARLES: What
kind of book is it?
I would call it an
action adventure.
It's got some funny parts,
but it's more action.
AUDIENCE: What about
the kindergarten book?
RACHEL SEARLES: I didn't
write the kindergarten book.
She's out there.
You?
AUDIENCE: Have you
wrote any humor books?
RACHEL SEARLES: Have I
written any humor books?
No, I haven't written
any funny books.
There's some funny
lines in this book,
but humor is not
my strong point.
Yes, you?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
[INAUDIBLE] or any other books?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I going to
write any other kind of books?
Yes, maybe someday.
I'm pitching a fantasy
book right now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
But any other subject?
RACHEL SEARLES: Yes.
I'm pitching a book about
an orphanage right now.
Yes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Did you ever
have any curiosity
about being an astronaut?
RACHEL SEARLES: Did I
ever have any curiosity
about becoming an astronaut?
No.
Astronauts are crazy.
To let someone launch you
on a rocket to the moon.
Would you do it?
No?
AUDIENCE: They're not crazy.
Aliens are crazy.
RACHEL SEARLES: Maybe.
Yes, you?
AUDIENCE: Are you going to do
an autobiography on yourself?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I going to
do an autobiography on myself?
A little early for that.
You mean write an
autobiography, like a book?
No, not yet.
Maybe when I'm about
60 years older.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Did you
meet Aaron Hunter?
Because I know [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Have
I met Aaron Hunter?
I haven't, no.
Does he live in Los Angeles?
I'll have to look him up.
Oh, good to know.
Yes, with the glasses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Do
I think there could
be aliens in other places?
You know, there are about
100 to 200 billion galaxies
in the universe.
That's a lot of place.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Exactly.
I agree with you.
The odds are very small
that it's just us out here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the cover, which
picture [? shows him? ?]
RACHEL SEARLES: In the cover,
which picture shows him?
He's the blond
boy in the middle.
That's Chase.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Did you
know that there
is planets that have
chances of sustaining life?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do
I know that there's
a lot of planets that have
a chance of sustaining life?
Yes.
I don't know the exact number,
but I follow that in the news.
I think it's really interesting.
I can't wait to see what people
discover in the next 10, 15,
20 years.
AUDIENCE: Probably
a thousand years.
RACHEL SEARLES: Maybe.
Probably a thousand years.
I won't be around for that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you know
the fear of spiders
is called arachnophobia?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do I
know the fear of spiders
is called arachnophobia?
Yes.
It's also the name
of a terrible movie.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you gonna
write [? any books ?]
on Saturn or Pluto?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I going to
write any other planet books?
Well, I'm hoping that the series
is about four or five books,
so I'll probably
pick on some other--
AUDIENCE: Are you going
put them on YouTube?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I going
to put them on YouTube?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
Because I always go on YouTube.
RACHEL SEARLES: No, I don't
have any plans to put anything
on YouTube right now.
It's terrifying.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this the Milky Way?
RACHEL SEARLES: Is this
the Milky Way Galaxy?
Well, the one on the back
cover, I don't think so.
Somebody told me
which one it is,
and I can't remember right now.
It's a different one.
AUDIENCE: What is your
favorite part about the book?
RACHEL SEARLES: What's my
Well in chapter, I
think it's chapter 22,
I almost kill one of
my favorite characters.
That was my favorite
part of the book.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: It
was fun to write.
Other questions?
Anybody?
You?
AUDIENCE: When
you're writing, do
you like to write humorous
[? sketches ?] or like
[INAUDIBLE]?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do I have
a favorite kind of section
to write in my book?
I like writing the
dialogue sections.
I think those are fun when
people are talking back
and forth, because
they can be funny.
AUDIENCE: I mean, [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES:
Yeah, those are fun.
You?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
other ideas for books?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do I have
any other ideas for books?
Well, like I said, I'm pitching
about to my publisher right now
about an orphanage and monsters.
So that's not science fiction.
But right now, if I'm
not writing these,
I can write about
one book a year.
That's about the maximum,
because otherwise my brain
will explode.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: I'm a lost planet.
RACHEL SEARLES: Are you?
Silly.
Back there, yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell us a little bit
about your process
for writing books?
How often you write, how long?
RACHEL SEARLES: Sure.
My process for
writing the books.
On a daily basis, ideally, I
would write every single day.
But that doesn't always happen
because life gets in the way.
I prefer to write
in the morning.
I don't usually
outline before I write.
I tried to on the second book.
I tried to plan
that whole book out,
and I thought, oh, I'll
just have this road map
I can follow, and I could
just write the whole thing
in four weeks.
And that didn't
work, because when
I was trying to
outline it, I couldn't
get past-- I don't know what's
going to happen in chapter
four, because I haven't
written Chapter three yet.
So I pretty much wing it.
Maybe I have an idea
for the next chapter.
I go chapter by
chapter, but it's slow.
On good days, I still
try to 1,000 words a day.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Similar to
those lines, [INAUDIBLE]
do you remember
how many words it
was by the time you started
it and by the time it actually
shipped?
RACHEL SEARLES:
Yeah, my word count.
When I finished
that first draft,
I really didn't have an idea
what age group I was writing
for or, what the average
length of the book should be.
So I just set this
random number in my head
that I was going to write
a 100,000 word book.
100,000 words is long
for a young adult book.
For a middle grade
book, it's really long.
So on my own, I trimmed it
down to about 70,000 words.
About 70,000 when I was
sending it to agents.
And by the time I was
sending it to agents,
I had revised it
so much by myself,
that when it sold
to the publisher
we did one week of
revisions with my editor.
Really light stuff.
And sent it out.
I think now it's between 70, 72.
Something like that.
No, thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How many
book have you made?
RACHEL SEARLES: How
many books have I made?
Well, this is the only
one I have out right now.
And there's a second one
coming out next January.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Do I have
lunch with other authors
and talk about what
we're going to do next,
and how we're going to
make our readers cry?
There are a lot
of authors in LA,
and I do have a lot of
friends who have books out.
I'm going on a retreat
next weekend, actually,
with some friends.
We're going to-- we don't
talk about how we're
going to torture our
readers, but we do talk.
We help each other
out of potholes.
Say if you're writing,
and you get stuck,
and you don't know
what to do, and then
you describe the
scene to your friends
and they help you think of ways
to get back out of the hole.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you thinking
about making a movie yet?
RACHEL SEARLES: Am I thinking
about making a movie for it?
That would be awesome.
But we haven't sold
the movie rights.
It's not up to me.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES:
Yeah, maybe it'll
be a cartoon movie someday.
It would work well as a cartoon.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RACHEL SEARLES: Yeah.
Some people change
their jobs all the time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you know if you're
going to make a movie of this?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do
I know if anyone
is going to make a movie?
Somebody just asked that.
So far, nobody's
going to make a movie.
AUDIENCE: You should get one.
RACHEL SEARLES:
I should get one?
It would be nice.
It's been submitted
to producers.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you plan
on going on a book tour?
RACHEL SEARLES: Do I plan
When my book came out,
it came out January 28,
and my publisher sent
me on a book tour.
Just for a week to
schools around California.
So now it's kind of--
you get your moment where
the publisher pushes
you, and then you're
kind of on your own.
And you have to just
keep setting stuff up.
So now I'm doing school visits
just on my own in the LA area.
Anybody else?
All right, are we all done here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
All
RACHEL SEARLES: Right.
OK, last question.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Did you
get a lot of money?
RACHEL SEARLES: [LAUGHS]
Did I get lots of money
for making books?
Writing books is an act of love.
It's not a way to get rich.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to get rich.
RACHEL SEARLES: OK, thank
you so much for coming
in and listening to me talk.
I hope you like the book.
[APPLAUSE]